the green agenda has never been about
saving the planet only goofy teens and
20s somethings who obsess on Tik Tok
believe that the goal is control in the
globalist dream world a central
authority of some sort will decide how
far you can travel when you can travel
and by what means you can travel well
they like EVS for obvious reasons the
distance you can travel is easily
limited and monitored but in the end if
their sick fantasy actually becomes
reality what will actually become of us
auto
manufacturing Biden's job killing EV
mandate has dictated that nearly 70% of
all cars sold in the United States must
be fully electric less than 10 years
from now do you believe
that it's a government assassination of
your jobs and of your industry the Auto
industry is being assassinated it's a
transition to Hell Trump is Right China
produces 60 to 90% of the needed
minerals to create the batteries that
make these cars run so they can Corner
the market on EVs and if Joe Biden is
given a second term that is precisely
what will happen but there's good news
Americans are on to the scam they're not
buying into the EV craze it was kind of
a thing like a pet rock but the numbers
don't lie sales are in the toilet car
lots across the country are filled with
unsold EVS they can't get rid of these
things it's gotten so bad that nearly
4,000 car dealers sent a letter to Biden
saying his demands regarding EV
production are unrealistic joining me
now is one of the men who helped draft
that brilliant letter Paul larel of
course vice president of sheii
Automotive a great car dealership Paul
now even the customers and I know some
of them who bought these cars when gas
started going up because of everything
they did to the fossil fuel industry um
they're regretting their decision so
what do you
thinking well there's there's a vast
majority of them for sure that that have
bought the cars and uh in some in some
cases have returned them at at quite a
great rate um but I I do want to be
clear this is this letter and it's
intention and why we got behind it was
purely for the facts of the the
customers I mean we we interact with on
the showroom floor every single day
clients and as they come in and inquire
about these vehicles um and then wind up
taking them home and realize that hey
this wasn't quite the range I thought I
was going to get or it's more difficult
to charge because there's not as many
locations I think the the anxiety of
that is one part of it but then the main
purpose of this was really an
affordability issue you know when you
think of an everyday American um like I
mean we're in the Baltimore Washington
DC market we've got a lot of military
here um it's tough to think that a a
member of the military or a nurse or a
school teacher is all of a sudden going
to be able to afford a $60 $70,000 in
some cases $80,000 EV it's just not
practical so that's that's also a real
driving point to this letter and and
that's why we titled it the voice of the
customer cuz again not everybody can
afford this it's not a practical means
of transportation affordable
transportation for everybody um and and
again we're asking the administration
just simply to slow this down don't
force this mandate to where you know 67%
of every person is going to have to buy
one of these cars um your lead in was
exceptional too pointing out the fact
that the minerals I mean where are they
coming from who's going to supply them
Paul now almost 3/4 of those minerals
they're mined in a in a in a it's it's
terrible process to get these minerals
out of the ground it is not ecologically
friendly the big lie about batteries I
mean look it's a complicated question
but people should be able to buy what
they want they want to buy EV get an EV
but most Americans and I know you know
this they want to get in their car and
they want to go they if they want to
let's hit a road trip let's get to
Florida we're going to go we're going to
be there in two days or a day and a half
they want to go they don't want to go
and sit and for eight hours and charge
the car and and hope nobody comes and
you know puts a gun in their face while
they're having to charge their car I
mean that's not what they want they want
to get in their car and they want
Chargers work what what does a gas
powered car mean in American history
does it mean
Freedom it certainly does and I mean
giving people again that ability to to
to literally gas and go um not wait at a
charging station as you pointed out
where again these days some of those
aren't even working they're not at full
capacity um the infrastructure I mean is
another huge piece of this I just was
talking to a cent a moment ago in my
showroom and he asked me what the car
was right behind me when I said it's an
EV and he right away went oh gosh I
would never own one of those because I
would be shocked if I got on Route 50 or
or the Beltway and you've been on the BC
Beltway I'm sure Laura and imagine if
your car dies in an EV well if it dies
there's there's no jump starting it you
have to get it flat bed roll off to get
your car off the Beltway and out of
Harm's Way it's it's just we're only
asking again to take a pragmatic
approach slow this mandate down give the
American public more time let us make
cars too that have become over time a
little bit more affordable well Paul uh
New Jersey is Banning the sale of gas
powered cars by 2025 California uh
Virginia as well um one sentence about
what that will do to your business by
2035 excuse me well it's going to drive
it's certainly going to drive those
clients to go other to other states to
find an ice or you know combustible
engine car so they're not going to I
think succumb to the fact that they got
to pay a higher price put Chargers in
their home um they'll find a workaround
and a way around that and that's again
that's not good it's not sensible Paul
how many um EVS you sell this week
about uh I know it's single digits and
we have 30 stores and we're we're not uh
they're not jumping off the shells and
our day supply of a typical EV is almost
more than triple of what it is of a
normal car so it's it's a scary time for
us we're carrying a lot of these in
stock I mean my one stor I'm standing
right now I've got over almost a million
dollars in inventory that again it's
it's not an easy sale how many gas
powered cars you sell yeah over the last
uh here uh well this store in particular
about 100 but uh you know it's it's a
ratio that uh is not making a lot of
sense right now and again it comes down
to the the consumer demand isn't there
um and that's why again one of the main
reasons also we're asking for this just
just pump the brakes slow this down
please um Paul these are people who've
never made a payroll or never run a
business making these decisions and you
do it every day and it's a great great
car dealership Paul lower shell thank
you so much great to see you hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it anywhere
else